hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of idiots and abroad john where
are we today we are in denver colorado
that's not true
we're not in denmark we
we are in boulder colorado all righty we
are adjacent to lafayette colorado are
we yeah yeah that was in the evac zone
speaking of we're in the same room we
sure oh my god
also i usually introduce everyone first
hi i'm alana this is rahul that's jacob
and that's john harry uh welcome to the
first episode of the show that we've
managed to record in the same room
ah you gotta take it away
it's not it's it's not worth it if we
don't all touch jacob's scams yeah i'll
leave my legs wide open i've i realized
i've touched jacob's crotch like three
different times today you said that yeah
one
i've somehow missed all three yeah
that's i don't know i remember one of
them it was with a metal detector yeah
it was a magnet i tried to lower a
zipper he was trying to search for
a rod
um well yeah we're in uh boulder um
which is actually next to patreon people
of the people of patreon helped fund
this trip
where um
we got here and
then everything was on fire yeah oh my
god so everyone got delayed
um
john didn't get here till like 2 a.m i
was supposed to get here at 7. we could
tell the story in order
by arrival okay i was only delayed by an
hour yeah it was all right
we didn't wasn't too bad
jacob and then we showed up yesterday
um
and
we could see the smoke and uh it already
looked bad and um people were like you
were texting us about like fire and
stuff like power going out yeah so what
before you guys got here
oh bless you that's our live audience
before you guys got here um basically i
don't know what started the fires but
the winds were so bad that like trucks
were being blown over yeah and like as
we were driving it was like branches on
the road you would see like
traffic lights just bobbing up and down
like crazy that was terrifying yeah
we're on our list it looked like a
guillotine blade intense oh my god
that's where you're driving under it we
lost power for a little bit
uh but otherwise it seems like basically
the fires were as bad as they were
because it was a wind storm which is my
first time ever being in a windstorm and
that's what spread the fires as bad as
it was i guess
um
so
i think
a thousand homes they think have been
lost i will actually leave a link in the
description if you want to donate to
help people out
um because we met somebody today who
lost their
entire house and had to buy new clothes
yeah we were but buying some groceries
and they were lying just
yeah i was loading and i looked at the
people in front of me and they just had
stacks of clothes and i was like
what's going on like is there a
clearance or something but now
there was a clearance on there
oh my god
what were you gonna say quickly
get us off that last comment it killed
the mood
yeah yeah there was that part about the
toblerone
oh right yeah we were talking about
toblerone
because i thought okay then the person
in front of the voters get one yeah the
normal
this is the normal sized toblerone
and they're little like look like little
sandwich slices this is a yeah it's just
it's like it's a little triangle i
thought this was a big one
you can get smaller no you can get way
bigger i'm using the bigger i say i
swear when i was younger i bought a
littler one and they weren't little
slivers they were pyramids no you didn't
they were the same
length as they were width and height
square on the bottom you're thinking i
mean he's the european technically not
anymore
um but i feel like they're european
chocolate and they are i've never ever
seen well i'm scandinavian shut the [ __ ]
up you're from san diego
european is that the matterhorn that's
all i've ever seen it has we do is that
the marijuana switzerland
i think that is the matterhorn
switzerland yeah the one that is in
switzerland it looks like disneyland
probably do you know that's awesome um
so yeah you were given it large uh at
the checkout and the the nice checkout
man also
oh sure also from boulder obviously
agreed with you and rahul and i were
just like
what are you
described as confusing
and you felt like there was too much
going on because it's uh chocolate with
a
honey
the guy was like that's a complicated
candy
what do you want candy corn you walked
up with the toblerone he was like oh
my grandma careful there guy are you
foreign
but anyways many people lost their house
i will leave a link in the description
below or you can donate to help people
out um yeah it's pretty brutal so we got
here obviously an unfortunate time
we are very close to the latest effects
evac zone
however we haven't had any smoke um
because i'm like a canary in a coal mine
where if there were smoke i would be
dying because of asthma
i mean completely fine so it must be
heading in the other direction to us
so we'd like a toucan or something
i think any bird in a coal mine probably
wouldn't do it
don't worry about it
also it probably helped that there was
like a snow storm today that probably
might have helped yeah so
the 16 inches of snow has doused all of
the flames so everything's fine but yes
but the experience that we had the
burbank flight experts that we are
because it makes everything so much
faster um i don't know why you didn't
fly through burbank
so people don't know the secret it was
expensive at the time
it was going people back it was pretty
late but when the time we were buying
tickets so it was pretty pricey for us
to fly out of there so it's pretty cheap
for us i couldn't fly home it was like
eight between 800 and 900
to fly from kansas city to san diego for
christmas holy [ __ ] yeah and christmas
flights i guess my parents were like
we'll fly you out and then i send them
the prize they're like never mind
for me
um but yeah so we dodged it aside from
like bad wind uh and then jacob and tara
you guys got in next yes but when we we
took our we got our lift and we saw the
spoken stuff but then like as we got
closer to boulder and like leaving
denver we saw that like there were
sirens and stuff like in the roads we're
like oh no roads are going to be closed
and like yeah one we're like the main
road that would have been a straight
shot the boulder was closed because the
fires and we had to
like take this detour past a few other
closed roads there were pretty straight
shots
and
because of all these closed rows the
traffic was really bad yeah like all the
cars that were going to and from like
from between boulder and denver were
getting funneled into this one road so
that was pretty nasty
on top like all the weather stuff
because like flights were getting
delayed like crazy yeah which is because
of the fires in the wind yeah flying in
the wind did you feel it john
that's that's the worst wind i've ever
experienced when i was in the plane as
we were coming in
it was dark so it was just lights
but
i swear to you
i was looking out and i could see i was
on the wing i always get the wings so
that if the engine explodes i can see it
it's a cool shot um but so i was looking
at the wing and all the lights and i
swear
from my perspective it looked like the
plane rotated like two degrees like the
way the the way the lights like moved no
like i totally that was totally
happening on our plane too yeah we were
getting closer to the ground here
like above denver like the ta the plane
was like yawing slightly but it wasn't
it wasn't shaky yeah it was just it just
looked like it was yeah and i could see
the ground so i was like wait so
definitely moving turbulence
but it was being moved i think maybe
they were counteracting
wind or something
i don't know pilots are smart yeah
no i just thought i'd pilot in it
probably robots are smart yeah we had a
little bit of turbulence it wasn't like
horrible or anything but the plane was
rocking fairly a bit but when we got to
the actual airport it was fine i was
expecting worse because when we were in
lax
uh we were on the tarmac and they're
like oh
we just heard that it's too windy in
denver right now so we're not taking off
it was insane yeah you could like see
cars moving or feel the car moving like
it was it was brutal i'm not surprised
that the fire spread as fast as they did
but it's also supposedly been really dry
and then what two days from now we have
like that coldest day of the entire
winter which is minus 12 i don't know
what it is
what is that let me check i can check
fahrenheit is this minus 12
that's probably like mine
i'm going to say 60.
everybody give me a guess 20 18 20
21 oh you said i'm going to say
17.9 and 21.1 it's nine you stupid
[ __ ] nine nine degrees my friends
it's gonna be nine wow man well it's in
kansas i've been or kansas city missouri
i've been waiting for it to snow
and it hasn't but then right as i was
flying out it's gonna get down to four
degrees
in uh kansas city and snow so i left
the moment it happened but it's snowing
here so it's cool yeah yeah and it's
beautiful there's so much snow it's
beautiful i've only like seen it snow
once and it was when we all went to big
bear there's like snow a little bit it
snowed overnight when we were sleeping
yeah but that was great but now it's
like legit just been snowing all day and
we've been just walking around
frolicking had a good time john took his
clothes off he did very quickly take his
clothes off yeah i well all y'all were
all bundled and layered and i was just
in pants and a shirt and moccasins
i did accidentally wear monkeys you left
the house while it was snowing you're
like oh where are these and we were also
walking to where we were getting ready
to get like a cafe we all had like our
winter boots on and stuff and you had
your moccasins it's my scandinavian
blood it's true you keep saying that but
you're from san diego i don't i'm not
letting it happen no my dad did 23 and
you think toboran's a [ __ ] pyramid
it is
it's it's the matterhorn
anyways when i landed yeah um it was all
fine i mean apart from being delayed for
six hours uh but then i my uber picked
me up because alana refused to come pick
me up
what did you think that we would do it's
a long drive that was very unsafe at the
time
i forgive but i don't forget well it's
because they they have a kia soul yeah
they would never make it
there's no way um but so when i was
driving my uber driver
uh once we got closer to boulder there's
so many lights out and just no lights on
the freeway and no cars
we drove by a burned up truck it was
just blackened in the middle of the road
um
and then i swear we drove by on the
freeway
and hopefully this wasn't true or it
just put itself out there was a little
fire
right on the side of the freeway and i
was like that looked like flames and he
was like no no that's just lights
just lights in the bushes yeah but then
we drove by an overturned 18-wheeler and
i thought we drove by an overturned uh
fuel tanker but it turned out uh that it
was just a construction truck i mean it
also could have been and they moved it
well it wasn't overturned oh oh yeah it
could have been we'll review the footage
yes you recorded it yes
um but uh my uber driver said that
uh he was scared
um he felt uncomfortable
and uh you telling me was being a [ __ ]
yeah it basically driving it for us it
felt like post-apocalypse like yeah
like i mean not actually but you know in
movies when you're driving everything's
panicked could you see the glow of the
fire and stuff
on your drive i wonder if it must have
moved or something because when we were
in our lift it was less like smoke and
just an orange glow over the hills yeah
it was crazy looking but uh we were on
like broadway or somebody's like
guy
this this road is usually full of cars
even at 2 am well i don't know what's
going on
it was the fire
yeah naturally the fire was going on
raffle was really put out because um the
starbucks is closed
yeah two days in a row yeah oh my god
um he thought was really rude
i think he said um
do your [ __ ] job
when i said there are power outages
behind the wheel of it you don't need
power to make coffee it's true so
unforgivable how are you gonna pay for
all your burned clothes
how are you gonna buy new clothes work
you gotta work at your starbucks making
your cabbage
click your glass against mine you clink
you need to stir yourself check if you
all your cream date coconut is like yeah
that's [ __ ] gross
using that ooh baby
i didn't want to say because we've made
it like a running thing what is this
cocktail um so that we can you know get
the preamble to eventually releasing uh
idiots in a broad cocktail this is [ __ ]
oh
um also known as pussers british navy
rum
um
two ounces of that an ounce of orange
juice four ounces of pineapple and two
ounces of creme de coconut it's
delicious it's really beautiful like
it's two ounces i'm excited yeah um so
after you know actually pre-apocalypse
rather i went to buy some food before
you guys got here and we had our first
of multiple really weird boulder
encounter yeah i haven't heard of these
yet do you want to tell the story no
welcome to our first podcast
in person podcast everybody that's fine
i guess uh it was target yeah
yeah some dude just we we were
no we didn't even say hello no we did
not speak to smith obviously we got here
first so there was no toilet paper here
and all that stuff so we thought we'd go
and grab the the essentials so we were
at a target
and
this
guy just like came up to both of us
while we said can i help you for a
second or like can i help you oh i
didn't let me help you that's how he
and i was like cool do i look foreign
what advice do you have from boulder
it's like in
skyrim yeah dc or something that's how
we opened oh
yeah and then well let me give you
advice was what he said yeah
he's fighting over the story he's got
his toilet paper preferences it was like
cool yeah yeah he started telling you
guys like oh this is the toilet paper
they're really that's what i expected
and then he was like
i've been to austin austin
and
um tucumcari and albuquerque that i've
driven through 20 different places again
i was like this guy really knows his
phone
okay go on and
uh no i haven't got covered
yeah
like
unprompted a man we were not into we
didn't look at him we didn't interact
with him and his wife just goes paul
yeah and he just went off like and it
was a while yeah of him just being like
you know i've done this i've done this
and i've done this and i wear a mask
every time and then i i walked away as
soon as he said that i did not
acknowledge him and just walked up and i
said
oh that's dope
i just because what do you know oh it's
dying swedish
come on paul yeah
she was like paul how old were they he
was all sixties
he's probably he thought he was in a
different city probably maybe but it's
still like a
wild it sounds like covert of the brain
you've got brain covered
yeah my grandma calls it clovis so i
call it
new variant she's 95. she's odor she
works
[Music]
uh it's on it is awesome yeah okay i
keep seeing that
it doesn't have a light side it's a
custom job
why don't they have lights yeah those
dudes i have no idea you'll see
something like turn off no it has lights
it had lights before i flew here oh yeah
so my
suitcase closed
and then it was like oh i need to bring
the mic
and so i put it in and then i had
to shut it so i think maybe it's been
compressed
and something's happened in my mind
yeah but it's all good i see levels and
that's what matters
then we went to a record shop yes i
wanted to buy some records
dude comes up to me
while i'm in the soundtrack section
looks at something i've got and he's
like good choice
have you thought about have you let me
let me show you this soundtrack and he
pulls out vision quest and it got it was
better than that he he
he was like oh that's good but you're
gonna want this yeah
soundtracks you don't here's the thing
you don't need someone i'm aware of what
you're laughing at
it's a funny the story's funny good wait
the way you tell the story it's funny
well it's definitely
so
when when it comes to soundtracks
you don't make new recommendations you
have to have seen the [ __ ] film yeah
you don't go hey you know what have you
ever seen this movie no
yeah yeah like no let me see the film
you don't you don't you you can do that
with other genres you can't do that with
soundtracks anyway so he starts giving
these recommendations so now i'm holding
vision quest the album
and then he starts giving me trivia he's
already got some trivia for you it's
gonna blow your mind starts talking
about journey and all of this stuff
right and lawsuits cool and then he he
finished it off with going
like i am
i worked at blockbuster for like eight
years
so i know my movie so i know my movies
was this the same guy from target
no probably related yeah probably i keep
thinking you have i wanted to correct
your hand i wanted to pull my mask down
and be like
yeah
oh
yeah you know about the industry but
then i realized he'd be like
what
there is something bigger i'm not famous
enough to do that about somebody from
boulder being like i worked at
blockbuster eight for eight years so i
know my movies when you're talking to an
actor
he's like yeah
cool thanks man he was very friendly
compared to the other i hated it wait
rahul have you seen vision quest no well
then he kind of like yeah the authority
of what movies
that's true yeah and we i didn't know
the journey through we could me and him
could play that game all day about
movies you ain't seen that's true that
doesn't give you
you know what i mean but he's worked at
a blockbuster rather
can he quote karate kid three eight
years
don't know that he can't you don't know
that he can't talk maybe he can't
and then you know the third weird
interaction was just a woman who was
you know just
very detailed explaining to us what had
happened to her family in the fires
which i'm not going to complain about
which has been pretty like insane
no no one asked it was odd the way
she delivered it
however
you know [ __ ]
ass [ __ ]
no she was very nice though
no
okay
yeah hold on
this is all that this is all happening
before you have arrived yeah
there was another local that chewed
chewed our ears off
maybe they're just talkative in boulder
it's either talkative or like just weird
social there was another when we were
walking that old lady was just like
john john [ __ ] me that's right
john [ __ ] me off so much i'm sorry we
were we went to
a board game shop
and
you lot like i was clearly gonna buy
some stuff right so i was gonna like so
i picked up some crisis protocol stuff
shout out to atomic mass games if they
want to send us stuff
and then we was looking at dungeons and
dragons and we were and then you know
you guys went outside and left me and
john in there so i took what i wanted
for the checkout and then
john adds
one of these little puzzles so i just
threw it in on the chicken potato it's
sitting there i still need a vein for
there that isn't and then
um she's ringing it up
and she just and john for no reason they
haven't got a friendship they haven't
developed a rapport she hasn't helped
him with anything he just goes what's
your favorite board game
and then
she started telling him okay and here's
the [ __ ] up thing
she looked put out to tell you yeah
she was like
yeah but gave the most long-winded
answer
without and she stopped working
yeah on the bit where i needed to put my
card in the machine
yeah like right before it so in my
opinion correcting rahul's story
no i'm just telling you my side of the
story
but also just to correct him
everyone's correct in my stories when i
talk to people that work in retail
they can talk while i are doing things i
worked in retail for
countless years yeah so i thought that's
what was going to happen i was like
instead of instead of sitting here in
silence as she brings things up i'll
just ask her a question talk to me
that well i don't want to
um
but also
when i first asked she was like ah it
depends and then kept going and i was
like
what's that
and then and then she started talking
and i was like oh no and rahul like
he didn't even you didn't look directly
in my eyes but you did a few like head
turns towards me and then you had your
card and you started holding
well i thought it would remind her that
we have to do the yeah
it did not she she finished her story
before going back to checking us out
what was her favorite board game yeah
she i wasn't listening
she was cute what she was cute you could
have been a wingman she was cute she is
[ __ ] boring that's all right
no well here's the thing the answer she
finally gave she was like well it's this
board name called this from some local
guys that created it
uh
it was like you're trying to win favor
with the dark lord
it was the longest answer to say
i like different games depending on who
i'm playing with yeah that was the whole
answer ah
and then i said well how about you
expound on that
when i first got over dinner when i
first got to america
so actually we were talking about this i
have the wrong i come from the wrong
culture to be recognized
in the streets
we are as brits
particularly the english a what you're
looking at culture
that's we're the most hostile you are
really hostile yeah so it's like you've
got problems yeah what
what
as soon as someone's looking at you it's
a weird [ __ ] cultural thing
and
so at the moment now it fires off on me
all the time and i don't know if it
could be work related fun house related
this podcast related and i want to be
like yo what
and it could be like
maybe like hi huge fan a 12 year old
girl
tell me why you're here
you have
you told me not to call this person out
because i was gonna
yeah this was [ __ ] gross i agree
we went and grabbed some food
good we're sitting in some place
have our food and we go and then about
an hour later
i got tagged i saw on instagram and it's
a picture this woman has taken of her
nephew so she's got this seven-year-old
that was there who i do remember
and his hair was luscious he had
beautiful skin i'll tell you what i
remember because he kept turning around
because he's a kid
you know because you were staring at him
the whole time no i was like what yeah
i remember because he kept turning
around like kids do at restaurants to
just stare and i wanted to be like [ __ ]
you looking at wrong
anyway so it's a picture of him
out of focus
and then me in focus doing this
and it's not that it was
said you know can't believe i saw
uh one of my favorite actors out blah
blah blah didn't have the guts to go up
and say hi so i pretend to take a
picture of my nephew and tagged him in
it pretended
wait till your balls drop you stupid
[ __ ] seven year old [ __ ]
he's been a decoy
you're right he didn't know so [ __ ] him
yeah
and his entire family he was a complicit
you shouldn't
well we didn't know until last year oh
right drive back
back there that place is great
no no no dm then be like hey i'd love to
meet you and then you get out of the car
and you just walk up just go
and then get back in the car and drive
away you see them but you have to tell
them
so you can smack both of them in one
swoop um for the
record straight
i do i am so happy and like when anyone
comes over and says oh i love the show
or can i get a photo poco whatever i
always do it's never inconvenient even
if i'm eating i will just be like yeah
cool
all right don't sneak photos of me don't
sing photos of anyone it's violent it's
gross it's violating yeah i told my
parents about today on facetime
turns out my dad did it to a celebrity
in hospital
because dad was in hospital
my dad was like oh [ __ ] and he took it
and my dad's in hospital and they're
both in intensive care i sent you a
picture of a celebrity recently that i
was sitting next to it was jennifer
lawrence you've all done it oh my god
yeah i did at the gala oh you did it the
garden
you didn't tag me
my dad didn't tag i didn't do the
celebrity i didn't post it publicly
here's the difference it's for you yeah
dad didn't take the celebrity he sent it
to my mum so it's not violating it look
who's like look at it at home
i've had someone do it to me and blaine
had people do it to him all the time
weirdly like multiple times at airports
people would take pictures of blaine and
then like post them i think i might have
said it before the worst one that
happened to me was a guy who delivered
me something and then took a picture
outside my door and was like just
delivered this to alana and tagged me in
an instagram story with your like
door number i think so don't [ __ ]
talk what the [ __ ] man take the picture
i do have to
address
no one watching this will have this
issue and it we kind of do feel a little
and we sound kind of like douchebags
it's not super related
yours is valid
yes
the rant with this amount of passion is
probably not just yeah
i had one of those too
i feel like i may be told it was in a
7-11
um
i was uh buying something i don't i
don't remember what i was playing but i
was standing there in line and i looked
over and there was a dude
standing
at the door
face it like face to the door
just standing there and i was like what
the what is this guy doing is he about
to like turn around and kill us or
something and then after about like 30
seconds he opened the door and he left
and then an hour later
i'm on twitter and someone and they're
like oh man john
i wish i could
like talk to you i saw you at 7 11 and
like i didn't have the like the balls to
talk to you
and i'm pretty sure that that guy
was standing there looking at me in the
reflection
trying to psych himself up going okay
just turn around talk to him that
actually makes me a lot more sympathetic
yeah i i'm integrating no yeah no i was
like dude it's totally cool
picturing it in general i'm in agreement
that what happened to you is like
violating and gross and don't do that
don't take it without that consent just
[ __ ] off yeah everyone's gonna be
happy i'm not trying to relate to these
plebs i'm telling them not to [ __ ] do
it
however i do feel like we are probably
discounting
a lot of social anxiety and like they
probably really want to but they can't
and we just can't really yeah i mean i
felt that there was a wonderful there's
a couple of times i've said flat out no
and
one was a meal with my family and it was
just awkward and i was like i'll do it
afterwards yeah like i'll come back
afterwards i'm we were in a thing that
was it and it was fine it wasn't rude
the one time i was rude was that team
one time oh ah yeah i was with my boy it
was a girl she was up flashing her [ __ ]
lips
why do you think he's logged in with
body parts
and a dude came up and he was like he's
like yo love a zombie can i get a
picture
and i'll
me and therefore we are like
no
no
go away
this is the what no let's go away this
is our time stop it because you didn't
want anyone to know that you go to a
titty bar as you say it on a podcast
[ __ ] no that wasn't it wasn't a secret
then right this was this was just what
we do
it was our local it was just that one
you're not allowed cameras in there if
you're not allowed to take pictures of
the gash what makes you think you can
take pictures of the punters um it's
true so why the punters yeah the visit
yeah
yeah but you had a huge direction
no i didn't take a picture of this guy
but you know but you don't you don't do
that there's a certain decorum you don't
have a swimming pool changing room yeah
you don't do it it's brothel
i don't know like hillary clinton said
that she stopped eating in public
because everyone was always waiting
waiting
well that's what the picture was that
she's tagged me off on instagram
yeah
that's why i never like i just feel like
maybe we should spend more time
supporting rahul and less time
supporting the
victims of the fire
oh yeah yeah good point
um
that's why i like if i
did want to pursue acting i could
probably get up to like
brad pitt maybe like chris farley level
sure but i don't want to have to
experience that out in public
yeah so that's why i refrain
that makes sense but i could be i could
probably be one of the biggest actors of
our generation so why did you do uh i
think you could of your generation
the thing is you get more famous being
some bell end on the internet
well that's because all the people who
know me are all neck beards it's stuck
in their room
[Music]
you must be doing really poor for
yourself because we went to uh he got
leaked uh a miniature both of you got
leads didn't you and you didn't get
recognized i didn't check uh
hold on that brings me
to a moment i want to be a little
serious right now
i always [ __ ] on you guys
and also talk over you i did see that
comment
uh blitz
blitzboy69
uh you said it i always talk over
everyone okay that is partially because
of discord that's very true but it's
also because i'm socially nipped i don't
care uh hey i'm trying to talk here
uh but
i rag on you guys a lot especially
no no no no
especially you rubble
but the reason i rag on you guys is
because i know
that you can take it right
and if i don't this [ __ ] [ __ ] can't
take [ __ ]
if i don't rag
it's because i have no respect for you
well okay you said that today i have a
thing where if i'm close to someone i
mean to themselves i'm close to
nice twisters twitch i actually do love
you guys so much
we love you too let's get you getting
the drinks in
who wants uh
oh black cherry there are only three
black cherry one three two four
hot
oh thank you
hard pineapple strawberry i want that
hard pineapple no john i love you too um
it's been super fun doing this show i
appreciate everybody you got a boater
no i have a butt that's still pasta oh i
don't even know that might be a hernia
um it's called hemorrhoids
jacob i wanted to ask oh ask away this
is your first time seeing like a lot of
snow yes indeed like how are you feeling
about
i was just standing outside earlier i
think like a few of us were we're just
like standing in the snow just staring
into the falling precipitation [ __ ]
magical it's great i know like it's
fresh fallen so it's all soft and
crunchy on the floor it's that which
unfortunately like john like dove it was
no hands first and it was all pine
needles yeah i was like
[Applause]
yeah it was just like pine cones and
gravel and needles yeah we did also have
a problem driving because we did get
changed oh yeah that's right but getting
up a tiny hill
the car was just sliding um and it was
really weird were you were you next to
me when we got the chains
yeah and he was like i don't know
i'm not from around here i don't know
you
can't the store got a guy at the store
because i was like should we put these
on now or wait until we get to like the
bottom of a hill cause we were planning
to go up a mountain yeah we'll still do
that tomorrow yeah it will be amazing
the snow will be incredible yeah he's
just like i have no idea he's like i
don't know i'm not from around here i
was like where the [ __ ]
how do you work at the auto zone
where are you from sir oh my you just
hand feeding jacob over here
oh look at him
rahul
oh
uh in the vicinity that um it would
appear i'm not doing that i'm not doing
it i don't want to put my hand in your
hole
[Laughter]
jacob grabbed it a lot's happening
yeah
thing is right when you say someone i'm
not from around it
that usually flies
right mm-hmm but you go to someone oh
sorry mate hey do you know where the
nearest swimming pool is swimming 12th
twice i've mentioned so i never go
swimming he loves swimming pool and i go
i'm not from around here when you work
yeah at an auto zone yeah
where do you get transport food from new
york yeah it's also a product in your
store yeah it's also it's car related
and locally related yeah so like how did
you even get the job there if you didn't
know anything about chains
surely surely plenty of people this
might be the hot item right now
right no not from renault it was very
odd he was nice about it but it was
amazing someone
what from choosing [ __ ] why did you do
yeah why did you just stay whatever your
body right
there the car rental place
where we got rented the car yeah the
soul yeah the dude who worked there this
is in boulder he did say he was from
chiswick chizik what's that i don't know
what that is in 10 minutes from where i
lived back in london oh really yeah
and he had an american accent yeah
no both
put it back i'm at an australian today
yeah i heard her accent and i was like
where are you in target oh is that who
you're talking to yeah i was like where
are you from she's like australia and i
was like me too
crackers
oh no that was a lady
[Laughter]
pocket and he's like walk by and so i
started walking by with the cart just
being all casual and then i started
passing her i was like i gotta do a joke
about not thinking about her
about like moving my giant dick but then
it just so happened that it was like
right in front of her and she's like
what are you doing it's fine anyways
australians can handle yeah she found it
funny but i was like what are the
chances of two australians being in
boulder and you've also met somebody
from school i guess this place isn't
that small no but someone from australia
yeah
yeah so i said oh my god i met someone
from what she's from melbourne so it
wasn't close by all right
if i said i met someone from the uk cool
10 minutes from my house yeah
your house
you said you're from chisholm or where
are you from
[Laughter]
yeah
i just remember at target hearing like a
cacophony of australian accents it was
just cute and i was like oh god
it was just
great
there's scissors
yeah and the cause is
with a weird person
and it was one of those things where i
didn't interact with them at all but i
was just watching them in anger
which was at the airport and i
understand you know people are getting
covered fatigued
um everything like that they're you know
maybe they're vexed and boosted they and
they feel the mask is like
unnecessary whatever but this lady
was acting like a child
she
the whole time we were sitting there
waiting for the plane she had her mask
down under her mouth and then the
employees would come by and be like man
you need to have your mask up you should
go oh oh yeah totally put it up and then
like as they're walking away just lower
it back down again and i was like oh my
god
um and then when we went like even when
we got went through flight thing she was
right behind me and i was frustrated by
that because i've been watching her
glaring at her for the past 30 minutes
and she did the same thing where they
like told her to put it up when she was
scanning her ticket and they were
waiting to get on the planet and glance
back and it was down again
and then
she sat two rows in front of me
and the whole time like the moment we
sat down she just took her mask off and
the tins came it was it was a repeat
like over and over the whole flight
she just kept taking it off and she's
like oh i have snacks which that's
understandable but then she finished
eating
and
it basically i was just the whole time
it's just extremely selfish yeah i was
just watching the flight attendant i
just felt bad for the flight attendants
they kept having to come by and be like
[ __ ]
oh wait come on
when we was on the plane ah we got we
got our flight
and
on the plane
i know if
i said to you there are no people of
color on the plane
yeah oh yeah right
so people are standing up right there
yeah but when the plane land did
[Laughter]
when the plane landed
[ __ ] like
the seatbelt lights were still on
in in you in chorus
a bunch of white folks
all the belts came up and they're
[ __ ] we're still moving oh
we're doing the slow cool in it yeah
bags are coming down and they're like
hey hey okay okay okay sit the [ __ ] down
so they do
and then it didn't take long granted it
took about 20 seconds and then they went
and a chorus again of white folk got up
and i said i told you i said look at
them acting like there's a sale on
mayonnaise
and actually i said
like we got we landed in denver and
they're like um the jet way is still not
connected so uh we're waiting on
somebody to come connect the jet way and
as soon like in the middle of that
announcement
everybody was standing up and it's like
anywhere like everyone always does that
i literally know where to go i don't do
it they don't do it because i don't want
to like
stand in this
i don't get it i i'm not an irritable
person i think the one thing that makes
me like mad
just very very quickly is people not
clearing their [ __ ] bins from the
line like when you've when you've gone
through the airport security you've got
your tray where you've like got your
because i'm like you've done this and
there are six of them so everyone else
has to wait longer and i'm just like and
i will stare at them and stack their
trays and then put them away and be like
it says stack them yeah why are none of
you doing it you can [ __ ] drive
something mental although i'll tell you
that sometimes when i get a little bit
[ __ ] down through tsa when i get random
checked yeah i leave my bins because i'm
like go [ __ ] clean up your prince
you flip it over i don't want to tsa
said i want to catch my flight let's not
go crazy
oh yeah but he does it's made me do it
and then i'm going to be late to the
mayonnaise sale it's like the time where
no i'm not telling that story
but
because i don't come off good on that
story oh oh really you come off great
i'm not straight
a bunch of times here so one of the one
times i was like probably went too far
with that altercation um
yeah anyway i i'll tell you one thing i
have done accidentally though
uh
i used to catch the train to work
or the tube i need to stand setting this
up and i put i put a cigarette in my
mouth because i was getting off at my
stop
and i must have i don't know what
happened to like where my mind was i lit
it
out oh out of the helic habit yeah so
it's there and i had the light in my
hand and at some point i don't know
where i was in my mind i just went
and then realized i hadn't got off the
tube the tube was still closed i must
have looked like a psycho to everyone i
was like
that was the psycho part
but you know when you brain fart for
just a second i think some people
probably brain fart when we land that's
like that tech talk that you i watched
yesterday that you sent of the guy who
punches the other guy twice
there's this guy on the street who goes
up to security guard the security
guard's filming and the screw goes
filming him and he's back and he's like
it's really long
winded i think he might have some issues
yeah yeah but he's like hey look i
suffer from this condition and i don't
take my medication and i can get like
that and i've come back to apologize and
the security goes like what that's all i
wanted that's all i wanted that's all i
wanted he's like seriously it's just me
out of the thing can i shake hand can i
just shake your hand
and then they do it and then he attacks
him
and he's like [ __ ] dick and then like
it was all a ploy
and then he's like i'm gonna stab you
and then this goes on for another what
30 40 seconds yeah yeah and he's like
i'm gonna are you even real security
guard
then he breaks down and goes i don't
know what it is man i told you i'm not
well
i'm just uh and the guy comes to console
him and he's a [ __ ] ruse again
he tripped him in he tried to push him
twice he'd have got me twice oh my god
me too i would be like you okay
poor guy he's on medication she died
that's the best tick tock everyone's
seen this week
i only looked at it once and it was
yesterday because you made me
uh you and jacob i don't look at it
super often i mean john you sent me a
little ones that i find genuinely
interesting yeah like vr ones or like
gaming ones i only see any cool ones
because i don't think you have a very
good sense of humor
absolute sense of humor you're good
all john cena are ones with huge teas
yeah that's free 100
can you believe that variety for you
nice they're pretty the [ __ ] thing
about tick-tock is right
um so dozier cat was on alive yeah and
she vaped
and then a warning came up
so they're moderating oh
vaping for the big ones right but also a
lot of people's videos are taken down
from like swears in the captions swears
in the subtitles
it's you can't say anything venus or
vagina right i found that out because
i found that out because i made a video
talking about how i got burns on my
penis because i tried to be a dry guy in
cold winter
try winter yeah what
what
i'm sorry try guy the drug dry guy
you know dry guy no it means you
masturbate without lubrication why which
by the way because the penis is bendy
what but yeah
[Music]
that's because you've been [ __ ]
mutilated but that's another
i'm sorry a dry guy is a guy who chooses
to masturbate
because you're mostly impromptu like in
bathrooms no but do you just fit in your
hands don't you just do that
no
why did it say so fast listen after the
dry guy i actually thought about this
why and i have i've announced it for all
you guys
that are like buying unscented
moisturizers
just buy lube
they sell lube oh yeah for like an eight
dollar bottle of water-based lubricant
you jack up for days yeah just probably
and i do maybe some people are too
embarrassed to buy lube
see
i i i'm not gonna buy a sex product
but now i do i'm sorry i still feel like
i didn't need to know why you would ever
go dry that's just the thing that you
know you don't always have you don't
have to clean up like am i gonna take a
[ __ ] shower every
where it's like it might crack out a
bottle of lube
that's inappropriate yeah but dry guys
is like a thing spit dries up too fast
but you don't need
in when it's not dry weather you don't
need lubricant are you both meditating
yeah
but you're saying you can burn yourself
well i found that out it happened in a
couple of weeks going back
so tick tock you can't write penis yeah
so that's what i see is like
i can't say vagina but i can say wet
slit right
i'll go one further than that
i've had videos pulled down because of
swearing or whatever or a caption
and then there are videos with people
who are way too young to be on that
[ __ ] app doing the most [ __ ]
sexualized dance yeah this this this
and you see because you're following
them
my notifications go off no but seriously
it's like what a [ __ ] what kind of
[ __ ] app is that that is awesome
well you can't have swear words but then
these [ __ ] idiots can can do these
it's chinese right
what yeah yeah because their censorship
is like a whole other field well it's
there's there's a chinese version of
tick [ __ ] called like do you or you said
tick [ __ ] that's that's a [ __ ] that's
more
whoopsie
there's separate apps and i think the
censorship on that one is different they
kind of
west they're looser with the censorship
but there are weird like how about we
allow the swears
um
maybe get rid of the
uh the racism racism and the sexualized
dude i would say allow penis and vagina
because those are medical tests yeah
yeah exactly it's just the name of the
organ um here's the thing i i learned
this recently
that
all men hate women
like
i saw tick tock words
talking about uh you know that all her
comments are full of dude like that it's
an issue and i was like yeah yeah okay
so then i started to talk again opening
up the comments because i normally don't
i just swipe like i'm gonna bring that
up in a minute and i started opening up
the comments and any time it was a woman
it's full of [ __ ] like aggressive
[ __ ] in like but it's all those things
are liked a bunch you know
guys being like oh yeah
so firstly i i'm you can tell from my
social please speak on this i i
uh read my replies on instagram and
twitter
too much because obviously you can see
from my quote yeah
tick tock never read them
they are [ __ ] garbage well yeah it's
a [ __ ] garbage audience and it's
usually
shared by people who don't know you
because that's the way that works right
whereas twitter doesn't usually happen
you're usually only really it's you're
only seen by people who follow you
whereas on twitter the whole idea is is
it goes on for you pages it gets pushed
it's new because the amount of times
people constantly act like this twitter
interactions are pretty bad
what do you mean well you're a woman
shut up shut up woman
i'm not saying i'm not saying that it's
that i'm saying that
it's tock in on hole in their comments
section is one of the worst i've seen
personally it's just
here i i had a realization or sorry are
you done no okay joe's talking over
this podcast too much listen i just want
to apologize sir comment dick splitter
420.
i understand i talk over people i have
bad social skills you want to be known
as a guy that splits a dick keep going
no i lost my train of fool the more
you're talking about how
met like no there was something about
the comments that the worst types of
comments
was it wasn't that it was um
[ __ ] i i can't remember now oh that's
one of the things that one of the things
i kept seeing
that kept coming through on for you
pages for some reason
is
is
what are you doing over there i'm making
sure i don't talk because oh thank you
sorry we didn't ask you to talk to keep
going all right never mind cause you're
not talking guys complaining
so what they'll do is they'll find like
a girl who's
i don't know doing a tick-tock dance and
she may have a uh a good body or
whatever the [ __ ] right and they'll be
like they'll stitch it and be like
350 000 likes this many reshares this is
how [ __ ] easy it is
and it's just like those duets and it's
so there's so much [ __ ]
i get if you hate women
ladies keep it up
but like to to almost to be that kind of
jealous and be like
my content doesn't get [ __ ] but jiggling
your tits does it's the lamest thing
she's pointing at
yeah
no oh wow
oh she didn't we don't have a camera on
those oh my unbelievable
wow what a [ __ ] what a great day but
you're not doing that like these guys
actually think they're being like alpha
or something or they're it's it's the
most
so okay i get that every day of course
right that exact comment yeah yeah
literally daily basis and all the women
it's so great being a man
sorry i suppose sarah just grabbed
it okay now here's the thing here's
something i realized yeah do you guys
remember
youtube comments like i read my youtube
ten years it will take it seems like
youtube has gotten better it is somehow
but back when like youtube from 2008 to
2014 or something yeah it was
cesspool
garbage people
and i don't know why
that's the case and it seems to have
changed a little bit at least maybe it's
the way it like
aggregates them and puts all the good
ones i think the moderation
yeah and people down vote yeah at the
bottom but
do you think it's i realize that no that
that is ticked up like what youtube was
the cesspool of the internet comments
that is what tic toc is now but is it
youth because we know that the demos for
tick tock is is one of the lowest right
and is it anymore just young people
being edgy because i hate their comments
i hate them on my videos
it's a lot of idiots like
whenever there's a science related one
or anything like that if you go into the
comments hello my friends
i love that guy
but yeah if there's anything anything
that has to do with facts you go in and
it's just
everyone with every single belief that
is not that it it's
just don't read the comments i've
decided i'm just not going to open the
comments on any tick tocks ever i don't
read the comments because when i made
one about batman it was so full of very
angry men then i got people who know who
i am replying and being like wow this is
a real spotlight on tick tock yeah i
don't care about that i waited to see
how long i would have to scroll to see a
youtube comment that is along the lines
of what you just said if i'm allowed to
speak
go for it okay uh this is from
permission granted
this is from matt brooks it says uh and
it's on uh an elden ring gameplay video
it says matt brooks female equals review
someone's gameplay i'm such a nerd t he
simps half a mil subs
oh man he has a point
i've worked in the game for 10 years and
he's like you just [ __ ] said
many things to attack women for oh yeah
write something up at least three there
were so many things that you could they
could they could twist there were so
many angles you could weaponize and go
against and like smarter ways that
aren't right but at least things you
could at least like put you in an
element of like make you look alpha um
completely complaining that this person
gets more subs than you or their content
gets more likes because they're
attractive is to me the lowest most
pathetic but i could also go off on it
forever because all of the top
male all the top gaming content creators
are male 1 by a massive margin and
youtube by millions the margin is
millions women can't get that success
yeah but but they did it through hard
work yes
the fact is that i get a comment like
that which means that dude was never
going to subscribe which means i'm at a
disadvantage automatically if a man made
the same video he'd be like oh i might
subscribe
this guy plays zelda right
that's good they're full of [ __ ]
cerestero great love him oh wonderful i
heard him say something on his recent
video each video
he's painting minis and he's like anyway
women are [ __ ]
for the record celesto would never say
that yeah
yeah
we're giving him a shout out his patreon
or youtube subscribe we adore him
sirestro is a uh a
guy who from the uk who paints
miniatures and he teaches you how to do
it and he's got one of the best i think
production values in his videos step by
step guides to paint great voice too
great voice he makes his own music hello
he makes his own music hello
today we are painting yoda from star
wars
is it all brush strokes
no no it's like that'd be cool it's like
surprisingly orchestral
yeah it's a lot of i don't really know
said that one video to do one miniature
is 60 hours it takes him 60 hours to
make one video one video
and i think the last one i saw had
seventeen thousand views
ah i might be short i don't know but it
was it was
sixty thousand six sixty hours for that
is what's like
i don't know what the point is sorry and
then she can get on youtube and just
[ __ ] wear a low-cut top i don't i
don't do that when have i ever done that
um
i don't know what my purpose was
into this poor guy he's great we have
this thing in ign called vph which
everyone hated but it was like our video
executive would run by it which is vph's
views per hour so he cared about how
many views you got per hour it took for
you to make the video oh
yeah
i was thinking about this recently
because
uh i've made a few youtube videos by the
way
i show i showed you the script yeah
how'd it go
uh i've scrapped it
because um yeah for those of you world
exclusive
i was making a youtube video i tweeted
about it it's been scrapped uh because
it was
too
edgy
and not enough attainment because you
know edutainment you take too much yeah
you dressed as donkey kong john what do
you mean that was entertainment it was
well i was making a very stupid point
that that was not true and made no i
agree with that
i agree with that and so it should have
been more stupid and ridiculous but it
most of it was like
history yeah it was at video essays i
agree and then it was like also here's
this stupid idea that's not real
you're
well here's the thing um
so on the youtube videos i make like the
peripherals one that one took
dozens and dozens of hours and that's
one that not views but i
because i spent so much time in it and
invested so much time that i do want
some sort of like i want people to enjoy
and know that people enjoyed it uh but
with tick tick-tocks yeah generally with
a tick-tock it's five seconds
yeah i'll have a funny thought and go oh
that's funny and then i'll record it and
alcolic one was great
that well that's so that's what i'm
saying it has like over a million views
now really and i hope you don't care
yeah because it was literally you didn't
have to work on it all it was was i was
cooking
in the recipe at a low amount of garlic
and so
these [ __ ] people and so and then i
just shot it and i shot it it's a really
good video in um i what's the video i
love your lip sync
video the pakistan i love that video and
that's literally just
but it's not just funny when you say
it's because your lip sync is so good
that it's like that violet but all you
had to do was lip sync something yeah
like it's lazy it's so easy to make
content for things
oh hold on just a little button of that
anyone who's out there who wants to make
tick tocks
my rule is
only spend
60 to 90 seconds on it
don't invest any time on it just fart it
out
yeah and that's all you gotta do
and make one little thing is instead of
holding your camera like this to do it
just set the camera down and it looks as
though it's there's more production
value but there's not beautiful
yeah across the three majors well i'm
not on facebook so i'm just gonna ignore
them but across the three major social
media
uh platforms
with twitter tick tock and instagram
each has a version of the retweet right
so the retweet of hey
site there's a there's a dignity to it
with a retweet
the tick tock version of it is some [ __ ]
green screening on a video going
yeah
and it [ __ ] the second i said the
laziest [ __ ] it could be a stand-up
comedian and they're reacting
listen this is my troubles and i want to
smash my phone
i feel like the green screens make more
sense because they they're like on the
edge of the frame yeah the duets it's
like what the [ __ ] because it it's it's
content happening and then it's
someone's face just gone
yeah and they've got their headphone in
and they're going yeah again i have
thoughts i hate tick tock i i really i
can't stand it you use it so much i love
it i don't use it
one thing that like i have a lot of
trouble with is watching how
performative it is not that other things
aren't but like i have friends who i
follow on tik tok that i'm like
because i'm watching them just like act
for views more than any other platform
where i'm like you made this video where
you're doing this stupid [ __ ] because
you're like for you page and i hate
seeing people do that but the duets
thing gets me because i'm like are we
just all pretending that you didn't
watch this before you did the deal like
blind react of course no one's talking
to me
no one in the history of blind reactors
stop yeah
you know the fan art where i act like i
haven't seen it before yeah
i just saw it because you're an actor so
it's your professional line yeah i
purely used it
that was kind of those are kind of a
weak performance for me i'd say yeah
that those were actually pretty bad
because i told him his tick tock tickle
miss he was very upset with me
i was like i don't know you tick tock's
a bit hit miss
and he was like hit and miss you're
you're taking the [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah sorry about that
he's hitting this
where are you it was a joke mine are two
everyone's are you i don't know i was
actually just okay i i would deliver
i
i feel like i've cultivated anything i
don't feel like i've built anything i
don't feel like i've had anything to say
i don't feel like there's a golden one
that i'm like oh but oh let me save that
before i
um
john how's kansas city
um that's a good point i feel like for
the past
hour and 12 minutes we've all just been
bitching i know
it's because we're so we we've been
spending like such a fun time together
[Applause]
yelling about something yeah kansas city
yeah how's it going um oh i have i have
a conclusion to my internet story okay
oh so i try to keep it quick because
it's all very boring but um you guys
know that i tried to get google fiber
the guy came and said my last not tall
enough
um and then it was a month or was two
and a half weeks of
just calling all these replays i got
rejected by a bunch of people finally
got internet from spectrum
and i thought i was getting fiber
but the guy came and he just gave me
normal internet
but i was like fine i have internet it's
fine
but then it was super unstable so i'd be
streaming and it would be
dipping out and all [ __ ] up
and so i called spectrum when they sent
a guy out and he tested everything with
his little machine he even like showed
it to me he's like see these levels here
and i was very interested i don't
remember anything he told me but it was
very interesting
and he determined that there was nothing
wrong with anything
that was part of my system and he's like
just so you know this neighborhood is
very old and it probably doesn't have a
very good infrastructure so it might
just be that
the cables running to your house
are [ __ ] like are bad and i was like
[ __ ] um would they think that coffee
it's like coaxial it's whatever
tv came
like since the 50s or whatever
is those cables i'm not sure exactly how
it works but it's old as [ __ ] um and so
but the thing what something i realized
after i after i was the spectrum there's
nothing i can do about it
when i got spectrum
the first time i called them
they were like sorry
we're not going to give you service
the same thing that all those other
providers did because of the several
because of the weird it was all this
weird [ __ ]
but with spectrum what i did was i hung
up
and then i called again and the second
time i called they were like yeah
totally and then they set me up with
interest
so then i was like hold on a second
what if i do that with google fiber
and i did it
and the guy came out the next day
and set me up with internet
after all the [ __ ] [ __ ] i went
through
i just had to the solution was just call
again yeah no not call again cancel my
account and then sign up for a new
account and schedule an installation
and that's all it was it's incredible
congratulations yeah so i now have
fiverr
you had like a whole month of just like
internet struggles
and i i've spent most of my savings and
everything while traveling and
everything in on the move
so like i was like
i can't make [ __ ] money and i don't
have internet i can't make [ __ ] money
and it was super stressful but now i'm
to be clear though i did ask you a
question about kansas city and you gave
me a story about internet
well that's my that's kansas okay
because kansas city let's see what else
did i do what's the guy that's why
you're there
what's the report in town the dallas
fort the gal report
um
i downloaded those apps
because there was actually a fun house
video if you guys don't know funhouse is
a youtube comedy channel never heard of
it where we talked about video though
yeah yeah
we talked about my tinder profile
jokingly and then i was like you know
what i'll download the apps and all
like all i'll check it out and so i've
been swiping match with no one but i
finally matched with this girl
uh and we talked a little bit and i was
like do you want to meet up for coffee
because
my methodology
is
let's meet up for a non-committal
just like
coffee a test anal yeah no incremental
anal yeah yeah and so after 15 minutes
if you're not feeling it you can just be
like oh sorry i gotta go get to
something and you can go like you know
[ __ ] off you slot yeah yeah exactly flip
the table yeah um cry
this girl's like actually i like to get
to know people a little bit more before
we meet up fact
fair
but we talked for like over a week
every day and uh that's strange yeah
yeah and like all i got out of her i was
like telling her all this stuff like
trying to you know
get to know her it's all about dry guy
yeah
after all of that the only thing i got
out of it
was that she was an extreme
she's an extremely picky eater
and she won't eat anything
okay and she
loves sex in the city those are the two
things i tell you right now something
hit me doesn't give a head
you think picky eating
[Laughter]
she was on tinder yeah
that was wait what'd you say
a tingler was she a ding though
well she didn't he knows it now yeah of
course i do he also she was a tank was
she a thing
yeah yeah she's a dick i mean
yeah
yeah comparatively the same video where
you were talking about your tinder
profile where you also like
put lindsey's dog's snout deep into your
mouth yeah
have you seen that we see the feeling oh
yeah you sure yeah
oh man that's right that's right yeah
the beam was good good time that was a
good video it was fun having you on the
video but so that's the lady but anyone
i think the ting situation in bold is
good
you think
yeah i think so i think if you're a bit
younger i'm i'm too old yeah it's
college kids it's a college town yeah
yeah i'm sorry oh yeah
young
not for me that makes me feel better
because i'm 33 now i'm fighting like i i
made this when i was doing the digital
apps i was like what do i set my minimum
age to and i think i set it to 27
because i was like yeah i don't want to
[ __ ] with wait like college kids well we
were having this discussion because a
tweet came up
uh because there was someone was saying
something about zendaya and
florence pew mm-hmm they're
florence pew is at 26 i think there's
going to be 26.
and i felt i
i'm 36 the 10-year gap is for me
i think pushing it that's like to the
most yeah
and even then
unless you're super like mature looking
or like then it counts on what
experience like the older you get than
the the wider it gets like if a 60 year
old is a 45 year old that seems my mom
and myself after everyone's i think
after everyone is 30 all bets are off
right
a 30 year old and a 50 year old if
you're weird but if you're 30 and you're
with a 50 year old if you're a 30 year
old and you're dating brad pitt he's 50.
that's a bit weird but i don't think
that's weird and i don't think he'd be
accused of being weird
whatever they wanted
we were talking about that
if you're
if you're 40
10 years past is fine
but like if you're 30 clearly 20 is
weird yeah that's right that's close to
high school i think yeah i think once
you hit 30 you've been on this planet
for 30 years
you've been an adult for nearly a decade
to find adults 30 long years well you've
you know you've had 21. okay look for
brits and stuff like that at 18
you can drive
you probably you know you can go on
holiday you can have alcohol you can
have sexual part you can you know what i
mean at 18 the world kind of unlocks at
21. i mean really like what's the
difference between 16 and 18.
i think once you hit 30 i think once all
parties have it 30
which and by the way i don't know why
i've got more london for this bit
one shot once you hit 30
once you hit 30 i think all bets are off
i think as a 30 year old you want to be
if you if you want to date a 15 year old
you're counting it's fine no
i'm saying once you vote once you're 30
anything up 80. it's up to you yeah yeah
if you're 30 year old
but even then even if that was the case
like that in a nicole smith situation
she was with like a nine-year-old old
titan going please die after after 30.
there's money
yeah do you yeah so i think age gaps can
start getting crazy i don't know when
the lowest age is 30. right john can you
possible and some ting
[Laughter]
painkillers and you guys have had one if
you if i did another one
if you was
you reached really far for that one i
have ready for another game
yeah and you go
to a club
and then you meet a team a kid and then
they're like
i'm 23.
yeah
but i don't want a relationship but you
want to come back to mine that's fine so
a 40 year old could have a one night
stand with a 23 year old i reckon
when i stand here
that's the same thing one night stands
it does but it's consensual
above age
no i didn't mean that yeah i mean no
they still haven't one night stands it's
you meet someone at a bar you have
nothing to go home you bang you never
see each other relationships
i'm 36 years old
what's my what's my weight i thought you
were like 40. what's my lowest what's my
lowest cut-off for one for relationships
for relationships
lois 26
yeah
sure even at some point no it all
depends i feel like that's the thing
anyways i feel like basically a virgin
again what's nice what's the cost for
the world
how long has it been
without sex
2014 oh they're going to say 24 hours
that is a while i remember watching that
i did two years once i remember watching
a jeffrey dahmer tape where he
did that
oh no wait there was that process
well that counts
she had a like a
like a um
nightmare vagina
like a dark soul
no i feel like we have a nightmare
vagina reference every episode
uh what constitutes a nightmare so i've
hold on i think it's individual i can't
believe i'm admitted we're not
a lot about how there was a very dark
period uh from like another vagina
from like 20 gross 20
13 14 to 2016 it was like that was my
lowest point
um and
uh
if we were gonna go cut it i was gonna
say something like this i'm not gonna
say it and then i'll shoot
um
and so at one point like
at one point i like looked into hiring a
prostitute because it's like a bucket
list also i'm so sad uh
and then nothing came of it but then six
months later i got an email that was
like hey you gave the prostitute your
email
no it's a fake email
well it's i have a separate email i have
like nine emails john smith at
hotmail.com yeah yeah that's the one um
but so she messaged me and i was like
sure and it was to meet her that night
and so we met at the standard would you
wet
uh
well this is when i was an operations
manager
uh did you ever so i was wearing no i
was wearing slacks and a long sleeve
button up
all right it's gorgeous
you gotta wear a hat
why if you're meeting if you go into a
brothel if you're going for a [ __ ]
massage if you're meeting uh yes
why i don't know and you just said you
go away
you wear ass you go away
um
why
it feels
i wore
like a long sleeve button up and slacks
like it was and it was
professional work attire yeah okay um
but so we meet at the standard
uh and initially i was so nervous that
she shows up and i was like
i don't like i don't know if i want to
do this and she's like get in the car
and so i hop in the car and then we
drive around the block and she talks me
into it so then we valet and we go to
the hotel room
um
and immediately hook up takes like wait
stop oh what's wrong no nothing
you just ripped a fat one yeah and he
lent it towards me oh yeah
i couldn't i want to keep because i
don't want you to feel um
left out yeah it's equality you look
horrified i am i'm so shocked
like you just suck god or something oh
my god i'm sorry
you went around the block uh yeah went
around the block and then we went in and
uh wait wait wait
into my the hotel room that i rented so
you met using
hoteltonight.com or hotel
shout out so you met at the hotel you
were staying at
no this was in i lived in la i rented a
hotel specifically so what's the
standard got to do with it isn't the
standard that's the hotel i rated but
you said you met her at the standard
don't tell me yeah tell me about it but
then you said you went around in the car
yeah she pulled up to the valet and i
was like i don't know if i want to do
this she's like get in the car so i got
in the car and then we drove around the
block and she convinced me sounds like
grand theft auto 3
we went off the back of a tow truck
but
so she talked me anyway and then we go
in the hotel room
um and i'm treating it like a normal
hookup yeah oh you're like what's your
stall sign
yeah
is that what you know so like yeah
things are getting hot and heavy and i'm
like i'm going to be a gentleman
and i'm going to go down
oh well that wasn't necessary no it
wasn't there i suppose it was a mistake
oh because uh also she said i was i was
your first client in a year that she'd
taken a year-long break and i was like i
wonder why that is but then i went down
they all say that
no
so
it ended up that she had a kid and the
way that i had figured this out
was that instead of the placenta no
it's just it's worse it was still it's
getting so much worse you guys okay it
is so much fun
i don't want to eat when you do this
i go to go down
large piercings like staples yeah like
what they were like large metal ring
like you know like a big bowl ring in
your nose
it was a bunch of those
like to steal her clothes and so was
like
not
something available something hit your
teeth it was like it was like uh it was
like a mad max vagina oh that's awesome
um anyways does she say to you
you don't need to do this
no because she's getting i don't
remember tell the rest of your story we
don't know
basically it is i mean after that i went
back up things happened and then we
were flying here you went along with the
call
no
no no
hotel room the call was just to convince
him to do it all right so you said you
didn't you gave us a mess but i didn't
go down on her in the trunk of her car
what the back seat i guess what what was
this you went up to the room you gave a
red
i about oh my god it's like telling a
story to my grandma we wear an app
yeah i took off my trilby
you took you weren't wearing that
no so you went down there yeah and then
what
i no i did not go down under i started
to go down and i was like never mind and
i went back up you've you've clearly
gone oh
and made your way down and then gone no
and i'm asking how did you style that
bit out how did you smooth that so i
uh
did you
kiss your way down and then you kissed
your way back there oh there we go oh
you're just having like a teaser
yeah yeah yeah yeah
again i'm still not sure if prosecutors
are technically in correct time i don't
know if that's offensive sex worker
well
i feel like trust me this is the legal
term yeah
yeah i'm i'm unclear in we're not using
i think it's i think i think i'm just
trying to be sensitive
i'm with you i don't want to i don't
want to get is
i think
if they are prostitutes and you call
them prostitutes it's okay it's when you
call people who aren't prostitutes
prostitutes
i don't know it's a derogatory yeah i
have full respect because that's work is
too broad because someone who takes
their clothes off
seductively
is a sex worker as is someone who
what about [ __ ]
they do it for a sandwich
an escort isn't necessarily a prostitute
no yeah
you you just go bawling or something
yeah
raw man
that's actually a reference to insomniac
uh
i think it was in vegas or he was in a
place where prostitution was like a
known thing and he hired two prostitutes
uh and then he took them bowling
nice cool relatedly our first patreon
exclusive is um the two of you because
jacob and i the audio didn't work
reading really negative reviews of the
bunny ranch dramatic oh yeah which is
very funny the next one will be a vlog
that john is editing of our trip here um
because we're like halfway through so
tomorrow we're gonna go see a mountain
and frolic in the snow i really want to
jump in it
do one of those running jumps those deep
right now sex workers rights advocates
are saying the associated press can make
a big difference by replacing one wide
an online campaign urges the editors of
the ap style book the go-to guide for
many journalists use the term sex
workers instead of prostitution there
you go prostitutes 2014 the appropriate
time with that
i think that's right well that was 2014.
that was we progressed like i think he's
going to work
i think that that's correct and i'm
comfortable saying sex
what year is it now
and again it's not for political
correctness oh here we go i want to
support that jesus
this is yet another episode where i have
to tell my parents that they're not
allowed to watch it one day it'll just
be a travel show and we'll just talk
about travel yeah we started strong they
can listen to the first movie maybe we
don't know i'm getting conflicting stuff
yeah i'm just gonna say it we go with
sex work someone here in this article
said for now for me i think i'll stick
with prostitute when talking about
people whose job is to have sex anything
else seems intentionally degrading
quote [ __ ] inaccurate sex worker
say that
sorry no no sorry if i prostituted
myself anything else
sorry [ __ ] [ __ ] anything else seems
intentionally degrading eg [ __ ]
inaccurate eg sex worker inaccurate or
archaic woman of the night
i think for now we'll just stick with
sex workers that's an easy blanket to
cover this one way
anyway um jacob um wait why don't you
wait
a while
and then uh
we like just hung out in bed for like
another 57 minutes
uh how'd you focus
uh is just normal missionary it's nice
yeah i don't remember maybe
uh i feel like but i do remember laying
there and the way i realized she
the reason she took a year off was
because she had a kid one was a rope
like the robo vagina the other is that
she like took out her phone and it was a
picture of like an infant as her
background and i was like
right
she's providing for her kid i just think
it's so then i then i left without
paying her
oh my god how does she have kids no oh
no i remember the last thing was that um
she had me call the valet
and then she just started complaining
for like 10 minutes about how valet's
valets are so annoying because sometimes
you'll go out and the car isn't there
yet and it like
it was like this is something that is
sick
she went on a larry david yeah just like
we did only about people taking pictures
of us yeah money into it so jacob
you saw your white family i saw my wife
how was it it was but it had been years
maybe like i think i asked jacob this
when he told us this uh i asked if his
white relatives uh touched his hair
and they do they said and they did right
yeah look at this
they can't help you is there a distinct
reason that you because you do always
say i saw my white family
are they just super
also jacob says it like
like like
they're white and you couldn't be
further from that it's so far from it
well he's not one how much do you like
[Laughter]
don't lie to me mayo's delicious
you know what i love cheese what is your
why is your gum like completely opaque
so [ __ ] so quick so thick
but yeah we saw the white family it's my
dad's step brother's family your dad's
oh so it's they don't know what they're
not even blood related yeah but we still
they're like mine so not only were they
so not only were they white they're even
more white because they don't even have
you're not even like they don't even
have a relative of color yeah yeah no
not at all but yeah because i always say
like on my
mom's side all my cousins
and their kids all
half filipinos
was what did you
but uh
yeah on my mom's side it's all
half filipino
women girls or my cousin
and then on my dad's side i have my one
white ginger cousin yeah you got a
ginger coconut i love that ginger cousin
yeah he's great he's really nice are you
the like around him are you the cool one
no god
no the problem is why i'm not school was
because of my brothers you don't need to
explain why is that yeah cause it's all
because of bread because brad was there
too it's not because of the destiny
clothing i didn't wear dresses
to this family i don't believe it the
shoes okay i wore shoes there were
destiny shoes but
yeah he's cool yeah what yes no don't
worry about it okay don't worry about it
i was talking about 16. john would go
down
john will
[Laughter]
you went to san diego oh no
my my mom's side of the family is in san
diego this was just like we went to
santa monica oh she went to a restaurant
yeah we just would do a restaurant
wait your white family lives for the
same city as you talk about work and you
don't see them for years i didn't know
this either oh i'm like oh my god was
there an exchange of gifts no this was
like no gifts just hanging out catching
up which one had the chiquita reward
that was mine that was my mom's side of
the family which is not white
no no all the dads are white i would
have thought a shakuta was white well my
mom made the trick
wait did you say that on your mom's side
of the family
all the dads all of the women are
married to white men yeah okay but
they're all filipino women yeah yeah
exactly just exactly quite a statement
but i get it tara and i break in the
mold when we show up yeah you're the
opposite yeah that's diversity
tara went
to the philippines and found jacob
and promised him if he came over
i haven't been i'm going to live a whole
life
the two of you
a question yeah if you could give me and
take as long as you want i would like a
uh a top five ranked list
of white people [ __ ] white people [ __ ]
just like stuff something that you're
like
no that's white people [ __ ] what is the
thing that comes to your head when we
talk about white people [ __ ] it's gonna
be jacob's top five hobbies
destiny
gundam
no i think white people probably don't
like butt stuff yes shoes too it's not
pure
enough yeah exactly it's not good in
church
fruit salad
potato salad
that's great
i think i'm more in agreement with
potato salad than fruit salad but hey
you're you are the people these white
people love them trifle
trifle is that all truffle no try full
trifle like destruction
trifling no the food trifle you mean
truffle
no a trifle i don't think that's a real
food oh [ __ ] are you saying trifold
trifle t r
i double f l
oh my god no that is a real thing it's
british yeah
of course
of course my references are going to be
from the company he spelled it wrong
what the [ __ ] is that it's like
strawberry i didn't spell it right true
i've had that before oh yeah what if i
had a triple before i don't know
you messed me up
all right i'll tell you if you play
what's the white white people stuff 50
shades of grey
50 shades of grey's white people [ __ ]
yeah that i think like the extension
twilight yeah
twilight first though you get it i asked
for five robert pattinson robert pencil
[Laughter]
kristen stewart kristen stewart
stephanie myers
did she write it yeah mormon mormonism
as in itself is one of the widest things
anna kendrick yeah
yeah that cup game where he's yeah
yeah yeah
well no i've seen i've seen asian women
do that magic
uh um
they're just copying white people
ping pong
uh
yeah but doing it on a tick tock off
from their kitchen like stacked and
angled and they throw the ping-pong ball
that's kind of cool
don't say that you're not white you
can't say that
guys hey you know who my father is
no hoverboards
hoverboards i don't agree with that no
no no no that's why it's fall
the first time i saw a hoverboard it was
one of those ones that it's a wheel with
the two feet pedals on the side yeah
it's not like a big wheel
it was this asian guy
with
huge like goat like it was seriously it
was just like
he it was like great like uh greased or
gelled up to where it was like it was
anime here shirtless
with those sweat wrists were you looking
in a mirror
i wish
tiny blue shorts
speeding down the street and i was like
that guy is like
it looks like nice [ __ ] like uh
roger rabbit he jumped out of an anime
i'm serious i'm seeing the hoverboard
okay with the lights on it
with a white kid
probably an 11 year old boy
in full pajamas matching holding an ipad
spinning
playing something
stopping picking up some cereal off the
desk back in his mouth spinning ipad
white shirt i feel like matching pajamas
is pretty white yeah pajamas owning a
boat
owning a boat it's pretty wide
okay so i still don't have anything for
the top five i think i'm known for
fishing we've got twilight fishing boat
like like a boat used to go out on the
lake a yacht
creation
like make a living well you put whales
on
i feel like i'm
the one of one or two people in a
majority white group because of my work
usually i'm around too and you say you
don't really like associating with your
own people i [ __ ] hate indians
uh no so i'm usually around can we say
that so i can pop that comment it's a
joke hour 43 thank you
so
yeah oh yeah so i usually feel like
i'm around a lot of white folk
and when they suggest certain things
uh that's when my radar goes off
hiking rock climbing i was going to say
hiking i know i think i know hiking
hiking from the white house
yeah the first time i came to l.a and i
zombie lot were like uh hey we're
getting together on sunday i was like oh
cool for what
hike for what yeah i agree to where
i thought there's a destination no the
hike is the experience i didn't go
yeah the sound of the whitest [ __ ] i've
ever heard coincidentally malcolm didn't
go either
oh really no that's when they bought was
it equipment that's where they bonded
was during hikes
to get wings
i would definitely agree with hiking and
mayonnaise i don't want wings i love
making
i love mayonnaise doesn't make it not
white people should um we probably
stopped yeah that's the thing is like
overly decorating overly decorating your
house for halloween or christmas or
christmas yeah why or for fall [ __ ]
hold the cafe anymore
for what you want me to remind you of
that they do just leaves i mean they're
done talking about white people okay
what no keep going i'm not brunch it's
branch white
oh yeah it's brunch
speaking of branch i'll tell you what's
white crepes
crepe crates crazy creeps anyone who
[ __ ] goes up and goes i'll have a
crap
it's a creep
why it's a creep
cmt cmt
country music channel oh
they're the ones who gave doc the bounty
hunters tv show after you got cancelled
yeah country music in general
bounty hunter there was like a recording
of him saying the n-word and then annie
cancelled his show and then like six
months later
country music channel is like we'll give
you a show oh my god and i worked on
that show whoa cool yeah did you meet a
dog did i have i not told you guys the
story then so i'm supportive of beth
chapman after she died
uh i was like beth chan is the worst
person ever that japanese dog's wife
yeah she's a huge kid yeah yeah yeah
she's dead
i was working on that show
my most vivid memory
i'm always heartbroken with someone with
large best passes yeah she's gone
so i worked on season three and she
finagled her way into an having an exact
executive producer role what have you
nailed it
we just double checks on them
who you're speaking of right now they're
dead yeah okay one of the worst people
i've ever met she's dead good riddance
[Laughter]
she cuz she worked her way into an
executive producer role and i'm pretty
sure that's why the third season was the
last season because she would just
[ __ ] every she'd come into post and then
demand to watch an episode and just
make all these crazy
notes that like we'd have to do but it
would delay everything and then she'd be
like hey editors let's go fly the drone
on the roof and she'd take them up there
and just like get super [ __ ] high and
then they wouldn't be able to edit the
rest of the day
she also when she would show up
and because i we were all friends me and
his pa
she does sound awesome
um
she was the most entitled [ __ ]
[ __ ] ever uh
and well this is actually another kind
of a cool thing
um when she'd arrive she'd roll up in
her escalade
open the door come out because we were
friends with the parking attendants
they said that she would open the door
with a
crown royal coke in her hand because she
always had like a bot like in the purple
bag she always had crown royale also
kind of positive yeah yeah um escalating
so this is my most vivid memory so i was
an assistant editor which is you you
assemble all the footage throughout from
throughout the day
beth chapman
um
so you assemble all the footage and so
you're going through the day because you
know the camera is like the gopros it's
a new clip every like 15 minutes or
something so
you're having to basically go through
the whole day seeing little
tidbits
and
at one point i get to a part in the day
where it's a close-up
uh on one of like the shoulder cams a
close-up of beth this far away [ __ ]
screaming at this woman this like
wrinkly woman
um she's like
i know you know where your [ __ ]
nephew is tell me where your [ __ ]
nephew is you [ __ ] liar
and then it slow zooms out and the
woman's in a wheelchair going i don't i
don't know
this was just somebody recorded this
yeah oh my gosh and now and
oh my god
that's a lot
and that's her and yeah that's pretty
cool and that was that was par for the
course
god yeah of course they are no they're
faked
oh
it's not heard
no that is fake you're right
okay
like that's gonna cause backgrounds but
like that
is what it was every day
of all the shoots and then
whenever they weren't interacting with
people she was just like
on camera yelling at the crew and like
just constantly yelling and [ __ ] on
people what did the crew do they just
dealt with it that's what that's my
go-to
when i see my my colleagues
saying oh this actor
[ __ ] bossing this crew around
shouting at this pa okay what was the pa
do how do you
know out
and what was she wearing at the time
i'm what they call a victim blamer
what's known on the streets is a victim
blamer is what he said did they get your
coffee order right
maybe they didn't
there's a lot of things that you know
what i i'm i'm really well behaved
because i see a lot of posts about how
bad
what is wrong with you rubble said he
was well behaved i see a lot of posts
about how badly behaved actors are
how easy we have it in the industry and
there isn't a voiceover all relatable
rants there's there isn't
unique there isn't a
a voice out there yeah to let you know
what we go through
right and our struggles we have okay i'm
sorry it's the hollywood class yeah one
percent who make who act well i don't
know you're a hollywood elite yeah one
person well it's pretty small one
percent
oh so only two percent of actors are
is what makes more than minimum wage
ah
so but people don't want to hear our
struggles and problems
must be hard
but it's your son
but do you remember when i don't even
know where to start fiber
huh john couldn't get google fiber you
can get fiber optic internet that's [ __ ]
i know
what's up you know what everybody's been
touching my nipples today
yeah but you like it oh
you don't know that well
okay right yeah tell your story okay
sometimes
they have different drivers in the
morning
[Music]
and then try to talk to you
so you gotta do fake combo
and then on top of that
they don't know your routine
yeah
i like put
no
take your foot off the gas
go left i usually start my day with the
starbucks waiting the [ __ ] car done
it's things like that and already now
i'm already off my kilt when i get to
set uh-huh do you know what i mean
yeah it's better
the other thing that annoys me about
work like working
is
you know
why are you talking to me
[Laughter]
i get it i get it i'm sorry that you
have to don't i get that you're excited
no i'm happy now you stop we're not
making
yeah
yeah would anyone else like they're also
like not on your same level okay tell us
about the cafe okay stop this
we are at the cafe this morning just
look at your watch first of all
first of all
i wanna picked the place
one of the most hoitiest toitiest places
actually well
rahul picked it bravo picked it
i paid 13 for a sandwich what
it's this big sandwich was thirteen
dollars yeah oh my god avocado toast uh
yeah holy ghost was also there
you got the croissant one yeah it was an
avocado
tartine
i got a tart radish on it which was
awesome yeah that's our team i i took
the radish off and i was like you know
what you're here to try it it was great
um
there were multiple times
where we were sitting there and everyone
else was being very quiet and russell
was telling some story he just goes
[ __ ] oh
[ __ ] old small place yeah and jacob and
i kept looking at each other because
you'd say like four times in a row
louder and louder
that did happen
[Laughter]
it was unhinged went on around about one
wachowski
just a lot you're talking about it it
was you got really loud and spicy at
that brunch i didn't get
angry at lana but you were ranting
loudly about lala no i was ranting about
we don't need to go into it no it's fine
i was writing about the dif the
choreography yeah action scenes and
movies that is true specifically yeah
that's true you're that saying that
without context sounds like
a transphobic
[Laughter]
yeah i don't remember saying [ __ ] old
it was yeah
speaking of and i was gonna bring up
matrix revolutions i don't want to talk
about it no we don't need to do that on
this show though
whatever
yeah we mean jacob spoke about book of
boba fett we don't need to do that
either
let's not talk about stupid
[ __ ] max rebo we don't have to talk
about entertainment on this podcast at
all you just gotta talk about what we're
talking about she's saying this is
because it's a conflict so she doesn't
have to because she's saving it i
already got to figure out what to do
about the [ __ ] indian comments and
you're so problematic i
love it i said i [ __ ] ate indians
with the awkward cut right between the
very end of this podcast
i was offended by that
that's hey that's on the list of white
people [ __ ]
he's offended
oh yeah
yeah that is that it's like
we're getting excited for other cultures
wouldn't that [ __ ] white chick at
that party go upset with me and jacob
for the white power thing
that's one of the top five white shits
well that's something
that's the audience yeah uh if i do a
mexican accent not an offensive over
exaggerated one but i grew up in san
diego and i know a lot of mexican people
and i can do i can do it
that's what i'm saying
that's not
what the [ __ ] was that
i'm drunk but you sounded italian can i
do it
when people do mexican accents i want to
know i'm not talking about any other
culture just
[Laughter]
they do there's at least one mexican
watching and i don't know
maybe your wife watched but because
people were like playing
white ask andy yeah because we know i
know he's not a real mexican
wow oh
do i publish any of this
maybe we shouldn't do texas
yeah texas mexican text mexican text
messages
no i'm talking about someone
let me give you an example we just got
here let me give you an example
can i
should i yeah do a japanese accent right
now can we wait
here everybody
and i do japanese accent it's
problematic it depends on the context
right am i being derogatory am i making
fun what's the target partaking
i did an impression of miyamoto and it
was [ __ ] accurate saying miyamoto was
like i loved you in midnight mass you
were great okay and i told you that with
miyamoto's accent did i [ __ ] up
is it on camera
no it's just we're right
we're at the hipster cafe where is
now if i said to you um
you met guillermo del toro okay can you
impersonate guillermo when you see
oh yeah
i can
when jacob does boba fett and he goes
is that offensive or is that an
impression that's the that's the
question that's a good question about
alien races
well everyone that's been
so um it's really nice to have you all
here in person um
maybe less alcohol next time no no more
okay more
well yeah we will have more controversy
and we're gonna do the vlog
and we might also play dark souls
is in the car oh we've got a board game
yeah yeah do that tomorrow i don't want
to do that
no no as long as we do it because yeah
we should definitely yeah so for the
next episode you'll probably be in
canada i start filming the fall of the
house of usher okay that's exactly the
rapper
he's gonna hang out with my camel he's
an r b don't remind me yeah he's uh
no no he's on b he hasn't ran ralph's
gonna go replace me with mark hamill he
already has partially in his heart you'd
do the same
you would do the same thing no i swear
i swear to you there is no patreon that
god people [ __ ]
i am never going to mention to mark
jacob no don't you pay for that viewers
don't you pay for that is that because
of the halo yeah we bring let's bring
this we'll burn this pastry under the
ground before we make this because you
beat him in halo
you shouldn't have done i can't deny my
nature i was using the controller your
[ __ ] on that's true yeah but he's
played a lot of destiny
well statistically the auto aim makes
controlling better much better not for
uh melee only what about the other one
[Music]
what about what about the three other
matches before that
what what oh wait that's when you were
being a little scavenger right oh when i
was picking a vulture
i hear a fight going on no fight going
on it might be bruce and then all of a
sudden you'll see both them dead
jacob you could argue that that's a
strategy it is a strategy right it's not
a noble one it's a strategy what's the
old strategy
can this episode be called okay
no it can't colorado
this episode is going up on the third uh
we publish on the first monday of every
month so our next episode will be the
first monday of february
oh
oh my god
yeah huge thank you to everyone uh who's
supporting us on patreon for helping us
make the show and get together and
record this
and also i'm really sorry
i'm about to throw up john is there
anything you'd like to promote other
than your vomit
i you know normally i mentioned
pizzaplasty.com
uh but how about instead i say come hang
out with me on twitch
john smith
everywhere but we hang out on twitch the
pete's posse hangs out there
it's the most inclusive exclusive club
on twitch
um
jacob
uh twitch.com jacob full second most
inclusive blaze on twitch no for real
what's your crew name
i don't really have one
it's like
i don't know i gotta figure it out still
but john and i play stuff together we'll
get back to halo
we're playing through all the halo games
playing through all the halo games also
fun house we made we made lots of good
stuff over the holidays and we'll
continue to play in the other tradition
still play a deadly premonition we're
gonna go all the way through we better
i'm committed people doubt us no i'm
committed
if i have to be alone in a room
recording for an hour by myself i will
flop no i want to finish that game at
the wheel yeah and i want to hear ryan
tell us more things about my god
my
red wheel of time
no yeah i've read the first like nine
out of one out of 14 13 or 14 uh do you
know what tavern means i don't remember
i read them all in 2014. okay somebody
called ryan tarvarian and i was like oh
my [ __ ] god it's a it's a reference
to the world time series where the main
characters are tarvaren which means that
like the threads of the world loop into
that oh yeah so everything that happens
magnetizes towards them and everything
that they do and i was like he's [ __ ]
tough aaron and [ __ ] that makes a lot of
sense
absolutely yeah oh it's incredible um
wrong is there anything you'd like to
promote
oh that was a good you almost hit my
[ __ ] camera lenses
[ __ ] um no but instead i'd rather
promote
people that on social like you make
content that
use my space sure
so serestero yeah i love them
check out celestro miniature gaming and
all of that ting nuke's top five
luke's top five baby no
uh so yeah serestero check him out uh
love his content keeps me very happy
keeps going and another indie content
creator uh bella porch
you need content great about books
and uh click the link donate some money
to those people that don't have [ __ ]
houses anymore i'm gonna leave it in the
description so please donate if you can
uh thanks for helping out and we will
see you all next month
bye